usually when there's one woman you're
the girl and when there's five women you
have to say oh she's the one who has
this personality and she so you have to
start looking at someone's character
when there's more than one often the way
I see my job is it's about kind of
providing a canvas really it's not
exactly what goes on the canvas it's the
space and then respecting that and
making sure it's protected the moment
when it's like no we're not women we're
scientists
felt so huge to me but then I was like
am I gonna do it a disservice by talking
about it I think we've been kind of
going through that too because everybody
is talking about it and not just in this
room but outside and our culture Shirley
yeah the fact that it feels radical just
to have five women at the center of a
movie brings light to the fact that it
never happens and it should be
normalized I get disheartened that like
in 2018 this is like what we're talking
about but then I get my heart feel like
fills with celebration and hope and
encouragement that we're moving in the
right direction at least do you think
this film and the characters subvert
those tropes of like the strong female
character I think it's great because
they get to be people and because they
are complex they have their strengths
they have their weaknesses they show
different sides of themselves each and
every one
I hope this marks like the the real can
the continuation of a sea-change
obviously we made this movie before last
year but the three highest-grossing
films were with women at the center it
should be celebrated but it shouldn't be
such an oddity because it in addition to
being necessary to continue this
cultural conversation it's also like
monetarily makes sense because people
want to go see those things
[Music]
you